the couple who runs together stays  together the Middleton and her new hubby  James Matthews have been getting sporty  on part two of their honeymoon in the  land down under the fitness fanatics  were spotted going for a long jog with a  personal trainer in Sydney Pippa looked  effortless in a baseball cap pink  athletic shirt black tights and black  sneakers her other half sported a Nike  shirt and running shoes paired with  black shorts clearly it's been a busy  honeymoon for the 33 year old and her 41  year old hubby the happy couple started  their trips staying at the brando resort  on a french polynesian island near  tahiti they arrived in Sydney on  Wednesday where they enjoyed a water  taxi ride past the famed opera house and  took in the skyline by seaplane and on  Thursday the newlyweds looked casual and  happy as they touched down at  Australia's Darwin International Airport  Pippa and James tied the knot on May  20th at st. Mark's Church in England  [Music]